[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ihn allen einen schönen
guten Abend wir haben Wintersport
Fußball haben wir auch später mit dir
Katja genau schön guten Abend wir
blicken gemeinsam auf unsere Themen
emotionales Wiedersehen die ersten
israelischen Geiseln sind wieder bei
ihren Familien die Übergabe einer
zweiten Gruppe verzögert sich
offenbar wie geht's weiter mit der
Schuldenbremse weder die Ampel noch die
Union sind sich einig auch das aus der
energiepreisbremse sorgt für
Ärger und einmal macht es noch
fernsehlegende Thomas Gottschalk
moderiert heute Abend zum letzten mal
wetten
das Freude und Erleichterung waren groß
über die erfolgreiche Freilassung
israelischer Geiseln und
palästinensischer Gefangener gestern für
heute war eigentlich ähnliches geplant
aber die Terrororganisation Hamas
verzögert den Austausch für Angehörige
eine wahre Nervenprobe dazu sprechen wir
gleich live mit unserem Korrespondenten
wie emotional das Aufeinandertreffen von
Geiseln und Angehörigen in Israel
gestern verlief zeigt der Beitrag von
Dominik
Lessmeister ein Gänsehautmoment der
neunjährige at Monda kann seinen Vater
wieder in den Arm nehmen oh hat und
seine Familie wieder vereint in einem
israelischen Krankenhaus nach fast 7
Wochen Geiselhaft auch Joni ASA kann
seine Frau und seine beiden kleinen
Töchter in die Arme schließen sie sind
auch deutsche
Staatsbürger ich freue mich dass ich
meine Familie zurückbekommen habe aber
ich werde nicht feiern bis der letzte
von den entführten zurückgekommen
ist Freude aber auch Schmerz denn
zahlreiche freigelassene erfahren erst
jetzt dass D Familienmitglieder durch
den Hamas Terror getötet wurden nun geht
es darum vor allem die freigelassenen
Kinder intensiv zu
betreuen die Kinder und ihre Familien
sind in guter körperlicher Verfassung es
ist noch zu früh mehr über ihren
emotionalen Zustand zu sagen alle werden
von interdisziplinären Teams
betreut die Übergabe einer zweiten
Gruppe von Geiseln verzögert sich
aktuell eigentlich sollten heute 13 oder
14 Israelis dem Roten Kreuz am
Grenzübergang Rafa geben werden im
Gegenzug sollten rund 40 Palästinenser
aus Gefängnissen in Israel freikommen
bangen in Tel Aviv zur Stunde versammeln
sich die Angehörigen und Freunde der
Geiseln für sie ist klar es muss
weitergehen ich bin keine Staatsfrau
oder Politikerin aber ich denke Sie
sollten alles tun um sie gesund
zurückzubringen so schnell wie
[Musik]
möglich sie hoffen nun dass ich die
heutige Freilassung der Geiseln nur
verzögert ja angespannte unklare
Situation wir gehen live nach telaviv zu
l walport lü die Freilassung der
israelischen Geiseln verzögert sich
warum also es hieß zunächst vor zwei
Stunden sie sein eigentlich schon dem
Roten Kreuz in Gasa übergeben worden
aber das stellte sich dann als
Falschmeldung heraus im Kern geht es
wohl darum dass die Hamas in gewisser
Weise nachverhandeln will sie er wirft
der israelischen Seite einen Bruch der
Vereinbarung vor nämlich in drei Punkten
einmal habe es einen Schusswechsel
gestern gegeben im mittleren
Gasastreifen dort sein Menschen die in
den Norden wollten getötet worden und
dann es sein zu wenig nämlich gar keine
Hilfsmittel aus dem Süden in den Norden
gekommen die Hamas möchte dass LKWs mit
Treibstoff und Hilfsmittel auch nach
gazastadt in den Norden gebracht werden
und dann geht es um die Zusammensetzung
der Listen der palästinensischen
Häftlinge die aus israelischen
Gefängnissen freikommen da möchte die
jas Änderungen haben da sind sie nicht
zufrieden mit den Namen die bislang auf
den Listen stehen die katarischen
Vermittler versuchen diese Kuh jetzt vom
Eis zu holen aber die Situation ist sehr
angesprannt die israelische Armee hat
vor gut einer halben Stunde gedroht wenn
bis Mitternacht die Geiseln nicht frei
sind dann werde man die Angriffe in
gazastadt fortsetzen das wollte ich
gerade erfragen was denn dann mit der
Feuerpause passiert aber vielleicht
gelingt ja doch noch sozusagen ein ein
erfolgreicher Deal Gefangene und
können zurückkehren was passiert dann
mit der Feuerpause könnte die dann noch
ausgedehnt
werden also wie gesagt diese
Unstimmigkeiten heute die waren
eigentlich nicht erwartet worden und
jetzt ist man hier etwas ratlos in
Israel man hofft natürlich dass sich das
als technische Details herausstellt und
lösen lässt allerdings hat die
israelische Armee wiederholt gesagt man
will keinenib Treibstoff in den Norden
lassen das könnte also ein Knackpunkt
werden wenn es denn trotzdem dazu kommt
dass die Gruppe der Geiseln heute noch
vor Mitternacht übergeben wird an Israel
dann könnte der Deal morgen weiterlaufen
und dann wäre auch theoretisch eine
Ausdehnung über vier Tage hinaus möglich
sprich ein oder zwei Tage mehr je
nachdem wie weit die Hamas bereit ist
zusätzlich Geiseln freizulassen vielen
Dank für die Live Information aus
telaviv l walpott war
das die ukrainische Hauptstadt Kiev ist
von den größten Drohnen en seit
Kriegsbeginn überzogen worden so
Bürgermeister Klitschko ukrainischen
Angaben zufolge wurden die meisten der
Flugkörper iranischer Bauart vergangene
Nacht abgeschossen landesweit waren es
mehr als 70 in Kiev fielen Trümmer auch
auf Wohngebäude fünf Menschen wurden
dort verletzt auch ein 11 Jahre altes
Kind deutschland ist einer der größten
militärischen Unterstützer der Ukraine
und auch dagegen gingen heute in Berlin
mehrere tausend Menschen auf die Straß
sie demonstrierten gegen Rüstungspolitik
und Waffenexporte auch palästinensische
Flaggen waren zu sehen als Hauptrednerin
trat die frühere linkenpitikerin Sarah
Wagenknecht auf sie war auf der
israelischen Regierung eine Zitat
rücksichtslose Kriegsführung im
Gazastreifen
vor das 60 Milliarden Urteil aus
karlsruh schlägt weiter hohe Wellen um
auch in Zukunft weiter in Klimaschutz
und den Umbau der Wirtschaft zu Tieren
wird kontrovers über eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse diskutiert und seit
gestern auch über das von Finanzminister
Lindner angekündigte Ende der
energiepreisbremsen zum Jahresende über
die verschiedenen Positionen auch
innerhalb der Ampel berichtet Ines
Trams wie nur die Milliardenlöcher im
Haushalt des nächsten Jahres stopfen
Antworten kommen vom Kanzler auch heute
nicht Olaf Scholz zu Gast beim
Landesparteitag Brandenburg betont
vehement er wolle an den Zielen der der
Regierung festhalten wie die zu
finanzieren sind sagt er nicht die
Erfolge die wir in den letzten zwei
Jahren hatten um vieles voranzubringen
vom Mindestlohn bis zur
erwerbsmindungsrente die werden wir doch
nicht aufkündigen und das gleiche gilt
natürlich auch für das große Projekt der
industriellen Modernisierung unseres
Landes auch das muss uns gelingen der
Wall sorgt das vorgezogene aus für die
Gas und strompreisbremsen das
Finanzminister Lindner gestern verkündet
hatte für Widerspruch bei der BD die
Bundestagsfraktion auch brandenburgs
Ministerpräsident wollen die Bremsen
beibehalten auch wenn die Preise der
Zeit niedrig sein ich hätte gerne auch
eine klare Aussage der Bundesregierung
dafür wenn diese Preise steigen sollten
wir wissen heute nicht was in vier
Wochen ist was in 8 Wochen ist auch
gerade der energiepreismarkt ist sehr
dynamisch darauf muss eine
Bundesregierung Antworten haben NRW
Landesparteitag der FDP andere
Lösungsansätze sparen auch am
Sozialstaat sei die nicht alles sei mehr
möglich die Schuldenbremse dürf nicht
gelockert werden Steuern nicht hochgehen
nachdem die Wirtschaft immer noch nicht
so in Gang gekommen ist wie es unser
Anspruch sein muss wen Steuererhöhung
Gift in der jetzigen Lage nachdem es
gestern erste Stimmen aus der Union gab
die Schuldenbremse zu lockern so wie es
grüne und SPD überlegen erteilt csuf
Söder dieser Idee heute eine
Absage die Schuldenbremse abschaffen
wollen oder so verändern wollen dass sie
letztlich nur noch Dekoration und keinen
Sinn macht das lehnen wir ab der Kanzler
und die Koalition unter Druck es gilt
Lösungen zu finden für stopfen riesiger
Finanzlücken wie das gelingen soll
völlig
offen den Grünen steht auf ihrem
Parteitag in karlsruh heute noch eine
heikle Debatte bevor jetzt gleich soll
nämlich über Migration diskutiert werden
Außenministerin berbock warb schon am
Mittag für den Asylkompromiss der EU
ohne Ordnung gebe es keine Humanität
sagte sie die Grünen dürften sich als
Teil der Bundesregierung ihrer
Verantwortung nicht
entziehen Thomas Reichard ist für uns in
karlsruh dabei Thomas Migration ein
wichtiges ein inzwischen stark
umstrittenes Thema bei den Grünen wo
verlaufen die
Konfliktlinien na sie verlaufen
insbesondere zwischen grün die
Regierungsverantwortung tragen und dem
linken
Flügel schint tatsächlich gravierend zu
sein ein Indiz dafür die Parteitagsregie
hat die Debatte zunächst auf den sehr
späten abendverband jetzt soll sie doch
ein bisschen früher in etwa einer Stunde
beginnen im Wesentlichen geht's da um
die Frage wie viel Kompromiss müssen
dürfen die Grünen in der Regierung
eingehen ausministerin Annalena berbock
sprach bei ihrer Rede beim Asylrecht von
schmerzhaften Kompromissen die nötig
sein und beim europaprogramm verspricht
die Partei die Grünen seinen bereit über
ihren Schatten zu springen um in Europa
voranzukommen dem linken Flügel geht das
es viel zu weit die Grüne Jugend will
per Änderungsantrag sogar durchsetzen
dass grüne Minister und Fraktionen im
Bund und Ländern keiner weiteren
Verschärfung des Asylrecht zustimmen
dürfen das wäre eine große Überraschung
wenn sie dafür eine Mehrheit finden bei
der Abstimmung aber deutlich wird daran
schon viele Delegierte hier sind
frustriert über den Gegenwind den die
Grünen in vielen Debatten im Moment
gerade erfahren und sie fordern dass die
Grünen in Regierungsämtern mehr
Kernanliegen durchsetzen müssten vom
grünen Parteitag Thomas Reichard vielen
Dank eine europäische Lösung für die
Migrationsfrage forderte heute der CSU
Europapolitiker Manfred Weber und zwar
noch vor der Europawahl im Juni
kommenden Jahres seine Partei wählte den
51-Jährigen in Nürnberg zu ihrem
Spitzenkandidaten für die Europawahl
wenn es nicht gelinge die Probleme bei
der Migration zu lösen werde die Wahl zu
einer Schicksalswahl für den Kontinent
so
Weber der gefährlichste Ort für Frauen
ist ihr eigenes Zuhause darauf wies der
Deutsche Frauenrat heute hin anlässlich
des internationalen Tages gegen Gewalt
gegen Frauen wie hier in Madrid gingen
weltweit Tausende auf die Straße um ein
Zeichen zu setzen sie fordern besseren
Schutz für Betroffene in vielen Fällen
geht die Gewalt vom Partner oder
Expartner
aus Weihnachtsgeschenke schon jetzt zum
Schnäppchenpreis die Black Friday
Rabatte die nutzen gerade viele für eine
Einkaufstour die Wochen bis Heilig Abend
sind die wichtigsten des Jahres für den
Handel und der ist nach Pandemie kriegen
und Inflation besonders auf gute Umsätze
angewiesen aber die Kauflaune die hält
sich in Grenzen Alexander Pool vier
Wochen vor Weihnachten viele
Schaufenster in München festlich
geschmückt laut Handelsverband stehen in
diesem Jahr Bücher weit oben auf der
Einkaufsliste die Buchhandlung von
Michael lemling hat das Jahr ganz gut
überstanden jetzt hofft auf das
Weihnachtsgeschäft na ja das ist die
große entscheidende Nummer am Ende des
Jahres wenn sie 10 Monate eigentlich
ganz gut über die Runden gekommen sind
und das Weihnachtsgeschäft geht schief
dann ist das Ganze jah futsch der
Handelsverband Deutschland dämpft die
Erwartungen an die letzten Wochen des
Jahres die Experten gehen lediglich von
einem geringen Wachstum von 1,5% aus
rechnet man die Inflation mit ein könnte
am Ende sogar ein Minus von 5,5% stehen
das hat auch viel zu tun mit psych mit
Stimmung aufgrund der außenpolitischen
Gegebenheiten die wir erleben
beispielsweise der aufflammende
nordostkonflikt aber auch der andauernde
russische Krieg in der Ukraine sind
beides sehr belastende Dinge das macht
sich wohl auch bei den Ausgaben
bemerkbar für Weihnachtsgeschenke wie
Spielzeug Bücher oder Schmuck wollen 13%
der deutschen deutlich weniger ausgeben
als im Vorjahr etwa die Hälfte hat
genauso viel eingeplant nur 2% wollen
deutlich mehr
ausgeben wird nicht ganz so groß
ausfallen in von Geschenke her aber ich
werde immer gleich bleiben ein bisschen
weniger würde ich sagen aber gerne das
was wir gibt gibt man gerne man muss
schonparen durch die Energiekosten die
jetzt gestiegen sind da muss man schon
ein bisschen zurückstecken ja trotz
glitzernder Auslagen das
Weihnachtsgeschäft wird für den Handel
in Deutschland wohl kein Fest
werden mehr als ses Jahrzehnte hat
Heidelinde weiß auf der Bühne und vor
der Kamera gestanden jetzt ist die
reichische Schauspielerin im Alter von
83 Jahren gestorben dem breiten Publikum
wurde weiß vor allem durchs deutsche
Fernsehen bekannt in zahlreichen
Gastrollen z.B im Traumschiff oder bei
Ros Munder Pilcher oder aber in der
Schwarzwaldklinik die Folgen mit ihr
können Sie übrigens in der ZDF Mediathek
sehen wetten das er hat die Sendung in
den letzten 36 Jahren geprägt und heute
soll wirklich endgültig Schluss sein für
Thomas gottchalk mit seiner
154 wettendass Ausgabe und natürlich ist
es auch wieder eine hervorragende
Gelegenheit noch mal auf eine große
entertainerkarriere und internationale
Topstars zurückzublicken in gut einer
Stunde geht die Liveshow in Offenburg
los über letzte Vorbereitungen und
prägende TV Momente Sven
Kass die abschlussproben sind durch
alles ist angerichtet für ein letztes
700 Kartenanfragen gab es für 2000
Plätze in der Offenburger messehalleeb
den Thomas Gotch über alles und habe
jetzt zur letzten Sendung noch Tickets
bekommen ich kann mein Glück gar nicht
fassen
also mega V allem weil man halt ja als
kleines Kind Thomas bei seine erste
Sendung erleben hat dürf und jetzt heute
das letzte Mal live dabei zu sein ja
einfach ein lebstraum Top die Wette gilt
es wir 154 mal wetten das mit Thomas
gotscheik er ist das prägende Gesicht
der Sendung mit ihm wurde wetten das zur
größten Fernsehshow Europas nach dem
großen Finale heute abend tritt der
73jährige nun ab da hat sich nun einiges
geändert und im Fernsehen hat sich
vieles geändert so dass ich sage es ist
auch nicht mehr das was ich gelernt habe
und was ich kann und was mein spezieller
turf ist hunderte Wetten hat gottschark
seit 1987 begleitet von spektakulär
bis ziemlich
[Musik]
SCOR und dann sind da noch die vielen
Topstars die got samstagabends auf Couch
und Bühne begrüßt
hat heute unter anderem dabeiad Helene
Fischer und shine David und Schauspieler
Jan Josef li eine Unterhaltungssendungen
natürlich gut drauf sein und werden auch
gut drauf sein bin ich sicher
aber Abschied dabei zu sein finde ich
schon auch
äh's auch traurig ein letztes mal wetten
das mit Thomas gotscheik heute Abend ab
20 uh15 Uhr live im
ZDF so jetzt zum Sport und wetten dass
die deutschen Skispringer erfolgreich in
die Saison gestartet sind Katja top die
Wette gilt und es wäre fast sogar ein
Traumstart geworden nur der Österreicher
Stefan Kraft hatte was dagegen und
gewann in kusamo Finland dahinter aber
Pius Paschke und Stefan lei auf dem
Podium und auch die anderen deutschen
überzeugten
nach dem ersten Durchgang fünf Deutsche
unter den besten Acht und eben von Platz
8 auf D fliegt Stefan lei ebenfalls auf
dem Podium und noch weiter vorn landet
Pius Paschke Platz 2 sein bestes Weltcup
Ergebnis mit 33 Jahren Andreas Wellinger
wird nach Platz 2 im ersten Durchgang
vierter Philipp Reimund 7 Karl Geiger 11
er aber fliegt allen DSV adländ davon
Stefan Kraft mit Tagesbestweite von 144
m sichert sich der Österreicher den Sieg
in
Finnland im Eiskunstlaufen scheint
Deutschland wieder ein
erfolgsversprechendes paar zu haben
Minerva Hase und Nikita volodin in ihrer
ersten gemeinsamen Saison sammeln die
Berlinerin und der gebürtige Russe
fleißig Siege zuletzt in Finnland und
auch heute wieder beim Grand Prix in
Osaka Japan wo sie vor allem stilistisch
überzeugten ja und beim Biathlon Weltcup
in Östersund Schweden blieben die
Deutschen heute noch ohne podessplatz in
der Single miix Staffel wurden Hanna
kebinger und Justus strelo 7bte in der
mixstaffel ging es besser zu Roman Rees
Philip navrad Sophia Schneider und
Vanessa Vogt holten Rang 4 hinter
Frankreich Norwegen und
Italien zur Fußball buundesliga und
einer starken Aufholjagd des BVB der
einen 0 Z2 Rückstand noch eindrucksvoll
drehte hier die Ergebnisse des 12
Spieltags Dortmund gewinnt das
borussenduell gegen Gladbach 4:2 Bremen
verliert gegen Leverkusen 0:3 Union
Berlin und Augsburg spielen 1 z ein
genau wie Freiburg und Darmstadt
Wolfsburg schlägt Leipzig 2:1 das
Abendspiel Frankfurt Stuttgart
ausführlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio und
schon gestern gewinnen die Bayern in
Köln
1:0 in der Tabelle keine Veränderung bei
den Top 3 Leverkusen vor den Bayern dann
Stuttgart dahinter tauschen Dortmund und
Leipzig die Plätze in der zweiten Hälfte
Augsburg ganz oben von Platz 12 bis 16
keine Veränderungen zur Vorwoche ganz
unten jetzt Union Berlin vor dem ersten
fC Köln ja und in Frankfurt am Main hat
sich ein neuer amateurbox Weltverband
gegründet der Name world boxing das Ziel
die olympische Zukunft der Sportart zu
sichern ein neuer Weltverband ein neuer
Präsident und eine komplett neue
Führungsriege world boxing will alles
anders machen als die IBA der
internationale Boxverband den das IOC
wegen schmutziger Geschäfte und
Korruption suspendiert hat und damit das
Boxen vor dem olympischen
ausstand jeder Boxer träumt davon einmal
bei Olympia anzutreten wir halten uns an
die IOC Regeln und garantieren dass wir
sauber arbeiten und diesen Traum
erfüllen der Holländer funderforce soll
das Amateurboxen reformieren und somit
die notwendige Anerkennung für den
Weltverband vom IOC erhalten mit Michael
Müller sitzt auch ein Deutscher in der
Exekutive von World boxing und das
aktuelle sportstudio heute um hal3b 12
Uhr bzw irgendwann nach wetten das so
musst Du sagen DANKE SCHÖN Katja und
nicht nur die Skispringer feiert
heuteute saisonauftagt auch hier zu
Lande starteten viele in die kalte
Jahreszeit im Harz lockt die Brockenbahn
mit einer Fahrt durch die verschneite
Landschaft ja Rodel Spaß für Klein und
Groß kostenlos und auch hierfür muss man
nichts bezahlen eine kleine
Liebeserklärung an den Winter und die
Schneeflocken die er so mit sich
bringt ja auch morgen bleibt es
frühwinterlich mehr Wetter gleich von
christaben das heute journal mit
Christian sie das ist für 23:15 Uhr
geplant aber sie wissen ja wetten das äh
schauen wir mal was äh das war's von uns
das wollte ich sagen schönen
Samstagabend und bis morgen
[Musik]
Gott guten Abend das Satellitenbild von
heute Mittag zeigt uns zunächst mal
viele Wolken über Deutschland hier ist
Schleswig Holstein hier die
schneebedeckten Alpen wir sehen aber
auch sehr schön diese Wolkendecke mit
den vielen Lücken über der Nordsee das
ist eine schauerwolkenstraße und für uns
Meteorologen ein deutliches Anzeichen
für höhenkalte Luft die zu uns fließt
und so gingen die Schauer heute aus
Nordwesten auch häufig wir sehen es hier
in rosa in Schnee über heute Nacht
kommen diese Schauer weiter Richtung
Südosten voran von Norden her bis in die
Mitte wird's aber trockener es wird aber
verbreitet frostig deswegen auch glatt
bis -4° im Osten des Landes frostfrei
nur im äußersten Westen mit plus 4°
morgen wird es auch im Westen etwas
milder mit 4 bis 7° im Osten kommen wir
teils kaum über die 0°ad Marke hinaus
dazu startet der Tag im Westen und im
Süden stark bewölkt mit einzelnen neuen
Schneeschauern aus Nordwesten an den
Alpen kommen noch mal bis zu 25 cm
Neuschnee zusammen das lässt dann
nachmittags aber nach der Regen von
Nordwesten und Westen intensiviert sich
aber und geht oberhalb von 400 m erneut
in Schnee über im Nordosten bleibt's
meist trocken und es gibt einiges an
Sonne und in der neuen Woche wird's zu
kühl für diese Jahreszeit und es gibt
einige neue weiße Überraschungen bis ins
Flachland tschüss